she's up all night to the Sun I'm up all
night to get some she's up all night
it's so cool get lucky is one of the
countless hits Pharrell Williams has
helped to create over the course of his
remarkable career as a producer a rapper
a songwriter there's not much that this
12 time Grammy winner has not done and
now he's adding a music festival to the
list of accolades we visited him in
Virginia Beach to see his very first
something in the water music festival he
calls it and found out why he wanted to
create something very unique for his
hometown artists architects athletes
academics when they read about all of
those interesting really talented people
who come from here they always say men
it must be something in the water I know
that same would inspire music mogul
Pharrell Williams to create this a
[Music]
massive three-day festival unlike
anything his home town has ever seen
this energy right here this is always
been
that's excited like okay we got this in
Virginia you know stretching miles
across the Virginia Beach coastline the
festival featured everything from local
businesses I'm definitely coming today
Sports is just as important as us two
big-name sponsors and even a pop-up
church service open to the community as
we walked around the festival grounds it
was clear that Pharrell is the ultimate
hometown hero I'm thanking him for
everything he does they called me to
newspaper yes destiny the most important
person city the DB and for him this
festival is so much more than
entertainment I feel like there's just
been so much like divisive 'no sin the
air in the community or in the country
in our country yeah
the spirit of division we have to come
together and not only celebrate our
differences but recognize it through
celebrating each other we can do great
things what is your vision for this
festival for people to be inspired and
also for these corporations to come here
because we have a lot of CEOs flying
down here to look around to see what's
going on and see the incredible
opportunity here we have wanted as an
area the the n-c-double-a championship
to come here and we've not gotten that
opportunity yet but who wins the
n-c-double-a this year
UVA so for us it's like this is what
we're doing is for we just want to raise
the awareness that like Virginia is here
and we are open for business
[Music]
we're like a cul-de-sac in the middle of
the east coast of America and we've had
our people but we've never really
congregated in a way where it you just
see us as a unit so we had the ambition
to do things differently
you know Tim Berlin is he makes music he
makes it very differently I mean look
and listen to miss Yeley
she's very different we're just
different people and we celebrate our
differences and when it came to music
well delivered an all-star lineup many
of whom were longtime collaborators over
the course of his career
[Music]
rapper singer-songwriter record producer
record executive fashion designer
entrepreneur a and our representative
which one comes first for you
musician music has been the skeleton key
to open every door for me so as a
musician which that word comes from you
know one who listens or is informed by
the muses which were angels like we are
interpreters so it's like having that
thing having that gift and being able to
share that gift with people complete
strangers regardless to what they think
politically regardless of how they feel
religiously it's the one thing it's like
music is a unifier you once told me and
I've never forgotten this when you do
music you see music in color
yes man I've never heard anybody say
that it's much more common many like
that I think most musicians have
synesthesia us musicians and artists we
call it a gift because it's what helps
us sort of identify with what it is that
we're feeling they call the blues the
blues for a reason you know so like
that's it's kind of always been you know
part of like the musicians vernacular to
associate colors with music my favorite
color is yellow okay nice it's mine too
your favorite color is yellow absolutely
I mean really yes it's crazy you have
only yellow as I know mine's yellow
because it makes me happy I think of
sunshine
yellow is the color Pharrell says he saw
when he created what some might call
music's happiest song where does it sit
with you are you like over it because
there are some artists that say that was
then this is now
yeah there are others that say no that
will always be near and dear do there
was definitely a couple years after
we're like little kids that just roll up
and just say happy look around there's
mr. happy and I might not have been
happy you know at the moment yeah but
you just have to accept it like the
universe has handed you this gift
you know that's helped so many people I
wrote that thinking CeeLo was gonna do
it you know but as as the universe would
have it it was me so I'm super grateful
you know it's only when you think is you
with the juice is when you start getting
caught up and there are people who are
the juice to be honest a is the juice
you know I'm saying jay-z is the juice
Strom
I'm the antenna you recently tweeted
this pinch yourself often because it's
the only way to assure yourself that
you're awake yes when was the last time
you had to pinch yourself I do it every
day
do you every day I wake up God is the
greatest
every day I was raised in Atlantis
apartments not even a mile from here on
section eight and now we are on this
section of the beach I'm super grateful
and still to this day my best verses
come from my shower or you know when I'm
swimming or when I'm next to water here
we are looking at you know this
beautiful ocean you know which
represents life and yeah I pinch myself
all the time I never forget where I come
from and that's part of the reason why
we're here we are Virginia it's because
this is where I'm from you know this is
a pinch being here love you guys this is
for you thank you so much my heart is so
full thank you
[Applause]
I'll say as hard as so full listen to
this guys the first day was a three-day
festival it totally got rained out so
let be were a little freaked out what's
gonna happen what's going to happen then
the skies opened up the next day but
people were so grateful and so excited
about what he was doing the artists that
he brought there and the love that he
has for that area
so nobody Keaton really cared about the
rain nobody was out we want our money
back because he really delivered big
time and he's already making plans for
next year he's a very special guy with a
big heart who wants to do the right
thing and bring attention to his
hometown community that comes so near
commerce his warmth comes through and it
really does talk about the roots of
music he's going back to those roots and
then you know creating this new thing
out of it it's just so fantastic
I know Beyonce has juice I know jay-z
certainly has juice too I think for all
got a little bit of juice - I think he's
a little more than a straw and I really
applaud what he's doing you can hear
more of our conversation with Pharrell
Williams on today's CBS's warning
podcast listen on your favorite podcast
platform wherever you get your podcast
we'll be right back you're watching CBS
this morning we appreciate that